c'était le 4 avril vicky jean-pierre
infirmières auxiliaires pour une agence
reçoit un diagnostic de lakovic 19
j'avais mal à la tête et puis j'avais
vraiment mal partout ça soit 42 jours
plus tard elle est encore déclarée
positive du test
j'ai passé là j'attends pour faure est
ce que je vais en passer d'autres vicky
jean pierre n'est pas la seule au fur et
à mesure qu'on teste un aux travailleurs
de la santé puis parce qu'on les teste
ces gens là on voit qu'ils sont
effectivement possible pendant de très
longues périodes de temps la période
s'étale parfois jusqu'à 47 jours une
observation souligné par différentes
études internationales
la médiane qu'ils avaient compté
constaté jeter 22 jours donc la moitié
des gens infectés ou observer la
présence du virus pendant plus de vingt
deux jours que ça veut dire c'est qu'on
retrouve des morceaux de virus dans leur
nez ce qui veut pas dire que le virus
est vivant mais pour une raison qu'on
ignore notre pcr donc notre test est
encore capable de trouver des petits
morceaux de virus après tout ce temps là
près de 5000 travailleuses de la santé
manquent à l'appel dans le réseau
atteinte de lakovic 19
québec veut les ramener dans les rangs
le plus tôt possible c'est pourquoi
après quatorze jours de quarantaine et
sans symptômes pendant 48 heures elles
pourront revenir au travail malgré des
tests positifs possiblement pas
contagieux mais ma connaissance au
moment où on fait des démonstrations de
chant pour ça ces travailleuses seront
déployés seulement en zone chaude selon
des conditions strictes mais surtout
aucun contact avec des employés covin
négatif des conditions presque
impossible à respecter que nous assène
stud on n'est pas capable d'appliquer
cette mesure de mitigation l'homme
l'institut national de la santé publique
continue de recommander deux tests
négatifs pour le retour au travail
une étude est en cours pour déterminer
si après 14 jours le virus est toujours
viable ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal